this NBA star turned his awkward
shooting form into a secret weapon
Tyrese halberton is putting the league
on notice right now averaging 27 points
on 52% shooting when you watch halberton
shoot you might notice that his form
looks pretty unconventional he has a low
release pushing the ball from in front
of his face rather than a typical high
arcing jump shot so where did this
unorthodox method come from it actually
started when he was just a kid Tyrese
wanted to shoot on a 10-ft basket but
didn't have the strength to get the ball
up with a typical motion so he developed
this unusual form to compensate for that
by the time Tyrese gained more strength
his shot had become comfortable most
coaches would advise a player to change
their shot in order to make it more
difficult to block in fact every single
coach halberton has ever had has
initially tried to change his form but
what they've all come to realize is it
doesn't need to be fixed halberton says
it only takes them one or two practices
to leave him alone it also probably
helps that he's been shooting over 40%
from three his entire career since it's
taken him this far why change it now